we're finally at the end of all of the
properties that as mathematics expansion
one student you'll be able to figure out
and combine and what I love about these
particular properties is they take all
these things this foundation we've laid
all these other properties have
established and use them in very novel
ways to prove very elegant relationships
okay so do you remember when we're
proving our property this morning what
was the property again what was it
called what's the short form this is the
angular the alternative segment right
when we prove that remember I say you
had to make a construction and I said
whenever you're making constructions you
don't know where to go a good idea is to
put the center on okay the reason why is
that once you've got the center there it
is you have all kinds of equal lengths
because of all of these are radii here
and you can take advantage of those
because equal lengths give you lots of
isosceles triangles isosceles triangles
give you equal angles and you can get
lots of stuff from that okay now in
addition to isosceles triangles circles
also create a bunch of similar triangles
they can't everywhere because there are
so many angles that are equal when you
have angles that are equal you get
similar triangles okay so I'm going to
show you three sets of similar triangles
here each of which gives us a really
nice property about the intercept in
these circles okay so here's the first
set up over here
and you can see I have a pair of what
what are these shapes on the inside of
the circle we call they're your cause
right chord and because they are they
clash we call the intersecting chords
they're not just chords that are out
there randomly they have to touch in
order to get this kind of configuration
okay you can clearly see that they
create similar triangles if you just
join up some of these chords right so
you can do this in more than one way but
I think for me the most obvious way is
along that edge at the top and also down
here so it might not be immediately
apparent to you that these are similar
but it's not hard to see what's going on
right think about some properties that
you know already
I know I don't need to I'll just stay
with black and I want you to tell me
where some angles are that we can use to
proof scenario I only need two pairs
sure give me one set again vertically
opposite so right in here you have these
two being equal can someone give you
another pair feedback to your properties
yeah go ahead Russell okay so I've
actually not labeled the angles at the
moment I've just got our length this is
actually the properties about length but
now tell me the property that you would
use to prove that angles are equal yeah
yeah very good so for example see this
arc down here which is a mobile you've
got this guy and this guy both standing
on that arc you could make the same
argument talking about this arc at the
top these two are standing on that
arctor that makes it doesn't matter
which one
let's just do this one over here so I
will leave the formal part of this for
later because it's really not that big a
deal you guys do how to prove similar
triangles very easily but you've got a
pair of excuse me a pair of it going
with their power equals their their
equiangular I've done okay so now the
interesting part comes from the
relationships between these sides okay I
want you to have a look at the sides up
in this small triangle and which sides
they correspond to in this larger
triangle okay so for instance side a in
this triangle is the one between the dot
and the double a line eaglebear right so
which side and the other triangle
corresponds to a it's C right you can
see they're both bracketed by those two
angles so a over something is going to
equal to D over something right
so there are that sorry what'd I just
say
no tell around that way everything so
these two sides correspond to each other
that's the ratio of those corresponding
sides so that really leaves the other
ones which are let's see here I'm going
to have this is the small triangle this
is the V triangle right so out of C and
D which one goes on top C and then
in speed down here does that make sense
and my reason of course is corresponding
side into the trade rules are the same
ratio okay now this is true but a nice
and even nicer way to say it is to cross
multiply right and you get a B equals
sue CD isn't that a nice incredibly
simple relationship between all of those
four different lengths okay so how would
we say this here comes the wording for
this right you remember we said these
are intersecting cords intersecting
cords think back to when we were proving
that think about the parallel lines of
the transversals when you've got a line
like this that interval like this and
you break it up into pieces when we call
those pieces starts with an i intercepts
very good so I would say my wording for
this is that it's about the product of
these intercepts do you see that so
that's why I put B to a blue and these
two in red so I would say products of
intercepts because that's what a b c and
d are they're intercepts and you get
products when you multiply them together
prior to intercept on one of these two
lines according on there and they're not
just any cords they are intersecting
cords they have to intersect to create
that pair of similar triangles that we
will take advantage of so product
internet on intersecting cords it's just
an equation so you just say they're
equal that's really nice okay